he was used to taking trips with private
jets and chartered helicopters to New
York and London or just from his home to
our candor headquarters the company that
owns some of Germany's biggest retail
chains prosecutors say Thomas middle
half misused 800 thousand euros in
company funds mainly on personal travel
he was also found guilty on three counts
of tax evasion middle half has now been
sentenced to three years in prison
prosecutors had asked for three years
and three months while middle Huff's
attorneys urged the court to impose no
jail time at all since the trial began
in May middle Huff has denied any
wrongdoing he said all the flights were
a necessary part of doing his job the
judge said middle Huff's statements were
dishonest and that the former executive
had improperly mixed business and
private interests the 61 year-old
considers himself a victim of injustice
he's called the trial a nightmare that's
damaged his honour and dignity having
spent many days in the courtroom middle
hoffs attorneys are expected to appeal
the verdict